لحظات جميله عاشها طفل سوري تحقق حلمه
اخيرا في رؤيه نجمه المفضل كريستيانو
رونالدو في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الطفل السوري كان قد ظهر في احد فيديوهات
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال مبديا تمنيه
مشاهده رونالدو لاعب نادي النصر السعودي
وبالفعل ساعه رئيس هيئه الترفيه السعوديه
المستشار تركيا للشيخ لتلبيه امنيه الطفل
لتنجح مساعيه اخيرا ويحضره الى الرياض
لتحقيق حلمه على رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي على هذه اللحظات بمشاعر السعاده
لتحقيق حلم هذا الطفل دعيني كل من ساهم في
هذا العمل الانساني لتحقيق حلم الطفل
السوري ووصوله مع اسرته للرياض
[موسيقى]
نه
شكرا معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ على
الدعوه الحلوه والله يحقق لك كل شي
بتتمناه يا رب وما مصدق انه اجيت على
السعوديه
[موسيقى]